pour des raisons de sécurité nous devons
garder secrètes la localisation de cette
prison
un lieu transformé en camp de détention
pour les prisonniers de guerre russes
ces hommes ont été arrêtés par les
Ukrainiens sur le champ de bataille
certains ont été grièvement blessés au
combat
en février mon convoi a été pris dans
une embuscade c'est là que j'ai perdu la
jambe
dans ce centre ils sont plusieurs
centaines mais les autorités de Kiev ne
donnent aucun chiffre précis
nous visitons ce lieu en présence du
directeur de la prison
ces hommes acceptent de nous parler mais
savent qu'ils sont écoutés par les
gardiens sucrésiens ils ont droit à
chaque jour à deux heures de télévision
le programme d'informations et bien sûr
ukrainien
parce que les autorités russes nous
disaient des choses et ici à la
télévision j'entends tout le contraire
j'essaie de comparer mais rien n'est
clair
nous demandons au gardien de sortir de
ce dortoir pour pouvoir parler plus
librement
ces hommes nous expliquent être bien
traités et autorisés à appeler de temps
en temps leurs proches tous parlent
surtout de quitter ce lieu dans le cadre
d'un échange avec les prisonniers
Ukrainiens en Russie
jeudi à ma mère que je vais bien que je
suis en bonne santé mais que j'attends
désespérément d'être échangé je la
supplie de ne surtout pas trop
s'inquiéter il existe d'autres lieux
comme celui-ci en Ukraine pour les
prisonniers de guerre russes mais nous
ignorons dans quelles conditions ils
sont détenus dans ces autres prisons